quel a été l'effet de la pandémie sur
les finances personnelles et quelles
sont les répercussions de la prestation
canadienne d'urgence sur l'incitation au
travail analyse ce soir avec pierre
carles michaud professeur à hec montréal
qui s'est penché sur la question
bonsoir monsieur michaud bonsoir donc
tout de suite je vous pose la question
quel a été l'effet de la pandémie sur
les finances personnelles des ménages a
comme tout le monde peut se l'imaginer
il ya eu des effets importants on a fait
une enquête nous livre la chair que je
dirigeais le cirano est par exemple on
peut voir que tout près de 30 % n'ont
presque un tiers des ménages ayant un
des membres qui a changé de statut
d'emploi il ya eu aussi des changements
importants au niveau des revenus
d'emploi une diminution de 8% des
dépenses mensuelles le 8 % ce qui est
énorme en termes mensuels et finalement
tout près de 20% des ménages où il ya eu
soit un paiement d'état manqués ou
reportés donc des impacts quand même
considérable et ces données ont été
récoltées de quelle façon
en fait on ne fait une enquête web
auprès de 3000 ménages québécois où le
chef de ménage les répondants avaient
entre 25 et 64 ans donc on voit
clairement que les gens sont frappés on
s'en doutait on l'entendait la
prestation canadienne d'urgence très
importante et plus de huit millions de
canadiens qui ont utilisé cette
prestation quand même viser très très
large question vos observations
essentiellement c'est une prestation où
un programme on n'avait vraiment pas le
choix au tout début le système
d'assurance emploi est capable de gérer
deux cent cinquante mille dollars
demandes par mois
et puis on a eu plus de 8 millions de
demandes
donc on a une prestation très large et
que visez donc l'ensemble des gens qui
l'a demandé et dans notre croissance
alors ça des gens qui ont demandé la
prestation canadienne d'urgence et la
moitié donc des gens qui ont perdu un
emploi des travailleurs à faible revenu
qui ont perdu un emploi ont demandé la
paix si us quand même beaucoup 49%
proportion des demandeurs qui ont plus
de 8000 $ en épingle 55% et valeurs
moyennes de l'époque donc près de 70
dollars donc décrivez-nous un peu ce que
ça nous dit ces informations elle ça
nous dit que le programme de la pcu a
atteint sa cible en termes d'aidés les
ménages qui en avaient besoin d'aller
sur tous les ménages à faible revenu
dont qui ont perdu un emploi
sipa en a on voit qu'en étant très large
le programme a aussi donné des
prestations à des gens qui en principe
aurait pu utiliser d'autres moyens afin
de subvenir à leurs besoins le dossier
dans les mois le con con con dieu qu'on
vient de vivre parce que il ya presque
soit la valeur moyenne de l'epargne
financière des demandeurs à 70 me de ça
vous fait dire que des gens qui l'ont
demandé qui avait pas vraiment besoin de
cela
c'est ça tout à fait on voit dans le
tableau 2 54% des gens qui ont demandé
la pcu avait plus de 8000 $ en épargne
disponible donc aurait pu utiliser leur
épargne pour subvenir à leur besoin
maintenant c'est important de dire que
ça veut pas dire que tout le monde
aurait dû le faire tout ce qu on y
indique avec ce calcul hausse
c'est qu'il y avait de la marge aux yeux
de la marge de manoeuvre surtout quand
qu'on va penser au futur
une deuxième vague ou n'est qu'une
extension du programme la pcu au fera
peut-être réfléchir un peu plus
largement de la ce niveau là autre
aspect que vous avez étudié
c'est l'effet de la pcu et de la pcu
pour les étudiants est ce que vous
constatez que ça décourage le retour au
travail
oui tout à fait les calculs qu'on fait
essentiellement démontre qu'un individu
l'eau dès qu'ils quittent la pcu la bce
pour faire un peu tôt au travail à temps
plein au salaire minimum pour les
travailleurs le salaire minimum cet
individu la paire éventuellement ses
prestations là et honnête quand on
regarde combien d'individus a gagné à la
fin de cette période de quatre mois
ben c'est parfois même négatif ou très
ferme en solde positif pour un étudiant
par exemple on a calculé que ça revient
à travailler environ à 2 $ de l'heure
durant l'été donc c'est presque du
bénévolat en quelques leçons mais est ce
que il ya un effet sur l'incitation au
travail réel où la très grande majorité
en ont besoin il ya une petite minorité
qui ne se sent pas
sans pales incitation à revenir au
travail tout à fait vous avez tout à
fait raison ici ce sont des calculs qui
tendent à démontrer donc la valeur et
fait maintenant est-ce que les gens
suivront et réagissent essentiellement
cette incitation là ça y est trop tôt
pour le dire encore mais c'est clair que
d'un point de vue d'équité ça reste un
calcul qui démonte l'axé c'est très
payant de retourner travailler on va on
va regarder le tableau justement que
vous avez préparé là dessus pour montrer
qu'un travailleur régulier père au delà
de 1000 $ donc 1037 dollars s'ils
retournent au travail plutôt que de
prendre la pcu c'est ce que vous dites
ont travaillé cette semaine au salaire
minimum à 35 heures ben on va perdre de
l'argent par rapport au gain de la pcu
exactement c'est exactement c'est le
travailleur est essentielle dans un
secteur essentiel c'est un peu mieux
parce qu'il ya une programme québécois
pour les travailleurs est essentielle la
pire tu donc qui vient effacer une
partie de ses gains négatif là mais ça
reste un gain très faible de 149 dollars
au total sur un potentiel de gain brut
de tout près de 7000 $ pour un individu
au salaire minimum et le travailleur
étudiants travailleurs étudiants 900 $
donc encore une fois quand vous
rencontrez un étudiant dans une épicerie
il faut qu'il faut quasiment les
remercier d'aller travailler parce que
c'est
c'est un gain qui est très très faible
que c'est presque du bénévolat pour la
relance
ici il ya une deuxième vague de
contagion sur quelles mesures on devrait
miser d'abord je pense qu'il faut
retourner aux bases ont un système
d'assurance emploi qui en principe
fonctionne bien et qu'il ya des
mécanismes en place de récupération qui
sont beaucoup moins drastiques que la
prestation canadienne d'urgence à un
système où site vérifications pour voir
si les gens recherchent un emploi
donc c'est un premier élément le premier
pilier chez nous on considère que c'est
important de retourner vers les bases
d'ailleurs c'est ce que plusieurs pays
ont fait dans l' ocde et deuxièmement
peut-être devenir complémenter ça et
c'est l'autre les pannes devient
intéressante complémenter c'est que la
possibilité par exemple de sortir
montante serré
par exemple sous forme un peu comme le
régime d'accès à la propriété dont
couillaud remboursement ou carrément une
exemption en termes d'impôts ça coûte
trop cher au gouvernement aujourd'hui de
faire ces mesures là parce que là genre
l'argent aurait pas été sortis bien sûr
cela on put un petit peu les rentrées
fiscales futures
mais ça demeure des mesures qui
devraient être explorés en complément
d'un retour vers l'assurance emploi
c'est ce qu'on va voir et on se souhaite
pas de toutes façons de deuxième vague
mais faut être réaliste les autorités de
santé publique en parle j'ai michaud
merci pour cet entretien fait les